[Music]
wake up buddy it is walk o'clock
maybe i should let him sleep
okay
[Music]
okay we'll go for a walk
i have an owner and he's superman let me
just iron that out
i should call me iron man
no
my dog's the best but he's not the
greatest with other animals what is new
with you fellow normal dog
i bit the fedex guy the other day who
was he working for general zod the
legion of doom
[Music]
fedex of course the federation of exes
not to be trusted
what is taking my owner so long
well well well
if it isn't the justice
league superman
what's going on
you're super strong i should be a lot
more dead right now right
my best friend is in danger and you have
to help me well we're just a bunch of
shelter pets but they're stronger than
you think the mighty oil
i didn't see anything show on
wheels the heck am i indestruct dog
great i'm the only one who didn't get
any superpowers
when one has an abundance of power
they have a certain duty to use that
power to
sorry
you were saying something
how much did you have to drink i had two
toilet bowls and a bidet but day two
which is which is crazy i didn't even
know that was a thing but it's like a
dog water
fountain oh out of the way cat child
hey deploy canine shield what is a k9
invade
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
[Music]
anybody want to switch powers